[Applaudissements]
aïe
alors les chéris c'est très simple les
chroniqueurs et moi même d'ailleurs je
vais le faire j'aimerais qu'on colle une
coupe merci mon chéri merci merci on a
collé une coupe une coupe sur le
portable
voilà c'est très simple il va falloir
faire un jeu puisque ramener la coupe
la compétition il va falloir la ramener
à la maison
[Applaudissements]
et cette maison et possède une piscine
et oui et donc si on dépasse la maison
le portable va dans la voix l'a très
bien
le grand gagnant donc comme dans chaque
coupe du monde il ya à garder sa demi
finale et c'est au final d'accord
sachiez que le grand prix le grand
gagnant le grand gagnant désignera celui
qui va se faire faire ici en hommage à
vg dream en hommage à l'équipe de france
de foot une coupe de football afc
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors je vous dis ah oui je peux jouer
ça peut être moi alors vous aurez le
choix entre plusieurs coupes que je suis
sélectionné je voulais voir les coupes
d'europe alors on va voir les
différentes coupes s'il vous plaît les
différentes coupes pas mal
après y'a quoi y'a quoi d'autre pas mal
les mecs pas mal si si ça on peut le
faire va pas tout le monde doit être
global post bac ça c'est pas mal batman
je le fais moi ouais fait le ouï dire et
j'ai pas mal ça lassad nouioui prise au
cinéma sur la tête de ma mère
ici à saint brieuc barque a annoncé
l'ouverture amos très bien ce qu'elles
auraient un peu vous mais ça me donne 10
10 en fait aller et voilà donc ça y est
c'est bon donc vous désignerez on peut
désigner quoi on peut désigner le dock
[Applaudissements]
or après celle de la couture va bien
c'est david da [ __ ] la professionnelle
de la couture de la barbe senden droite
regarde la barrière de sarah labarre des
airs de paris c'est la meilleure ça dans
la vie merci d'être là ça lamentable
suis content de te voir et qui était
magnifique
ils sont attaqués pas donc c'est sarah
la barrière de paris qui me l'envoie etc
travaillent avec elle vous inquiétez pas
c'est du très très très très lourd on
est d'accord laura concerne les hommes
oui là non plus on a ainsi abassis monde
mais ça peut être très beau sur une
femme de ménage avec une barre toi bien
là mais sans rigoler et les invités
aussi je l'aï motif qu on ait dit ça
joue il ya neuf chroniqueur plus où on
puisse vous m'aperçus snob mais cela
faire ce maître et chimanes déjà bien
votre chien on va faire un tout pour se
chauffer attention les plus nuls sont
illuminés du tournoi directement ça veut
dire que l'on va tous tirer les 10 ha
les deux pilules sont éliminés d'accord
et sachez que je vous le dis il y aura
un magnifique cadeau pour le gagnant et
quand je vous dis un magnifique cadeau
c'est vraiment un magnifique cadeau
store week-end c'est quoi c'est quoi des
mois
d'accord très bien je vous dis que c'est
un bon cadeau alors allez-y
venez tous la bonne est qu'on disait
alors c'est le tout c'est de lancer le
portable
oui il faut qu'il aille de plus près de
la maison sauf au cinéma sans tomber en
plus les gens m'ont laisse les
participants se mettront à côté de leur
portable ou par les armes et de
téléphone on se calme on se calme vg
dream et shy'm feront les les arbitres
monde et combien 1-2-3 stanley 5 6 7 8 9
10 ok donc y en a deux qui seront
éliminés sympathisants des deux derniers
tests à main alors attention on va
démarrer et bastia rien dans ce que tu
fais là british et la coke arrêté
no go n'a pas le droit de s'exercer que
l'indicé vous mettrez en fonction d'où
est votre portable je mettrais un stylo
ici d'accord je fais les règles même
temps quand j'ouvre chef
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il faut enlever
les coques l'école ben oui mais fois un
scotch et basse et abattent ont pillé
bassirou bâ fallait fallait le voir
avant moi seulement le fils bongo
c'est parti qui n'a pas de coke mois à
les attentions vase ils ont mis à bien
pire agents plus il y en a deux y en a
peu qui soient finalement légal virale c
peut faire rêver logement décent
ecoutez jean michel au pointage dans les
vraies mais je ne vois pas comment tu
pourrais pas dans les deux derniers
encore un génie à toi merci allée b
naïma ramener la coupe à la maison
benhaim attention je vous rappel le jeu
attention il faut pas le faire tomber
dans la piscine
oui bah je suis pas tombé non il me
demande quand même faut pas que ça tombe
à gauche à voilà on va le garder là on
va gérer les riders c'est pas mal arrête
de te [ __ ] de la gueule du monde mon
ami tu es bon jean meyer alors pour
l'instant tient jambiers bonnes gens me
jean me seydou badjan me c'est bon
aliens à 8
mamie on se réveille non mais je passais
en dernier lieu mais bien sûr aller
mieux que belaïd on peut enlever celui
de benji elle voulait envoyer 1 minute
et la belle s caudecostois rivasi mais
bon ça passait derrière a passé ses
nerfs si ça passe les deux dernières
pour l'instant ça se passe ici à amédée
mois frère quelques jours amènent col de
ces jeux vous regardez ce que tu écris
repas je suis me donne ce dossier mais
les prix toutes celles et tous ceux des
boîtes et coffrets toi qu'est ce que tu
as vraiment coupé un il a tout cassé
[Applaudissements]
très fort la région à fond ce pack back
roads elle va dit alors ça sera dessiné
les locales n'ont donc ça soit l'époque
quel travail est bon aux sports
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'adore jouer des allers simples et mac
dit ça t'aide à te qualifies allez vas-y
vas-y vas-y et le court d'où la saison
demain alors il va rien me suis moi vite
ap ap les points sans rigoler et tu vas
chercher du lait qu'est ce que c'est moi
qui ai pas touché en soit on plus non
messieurs abel a été qualifié de mafia
ma mère n'a perdu l'ombre ça c'est la
faute à pas de chance vous y attend
christine kelly du csa à la danse elle
adore et mais dis moi toi des mouettes à
mettre des talons de 22 cm oui massif
unis ce qui se passe je mais pourquoi un
peu d'élan pour ramener la coupe à la
maison
d'accord mais qu'on peut toujours la
musique de ramener la wii
[Applaudissements]
m
allez pas croire le risque est limité
sur casque racing lycées sur la télé
mines et ça c'est qui ça et moi à têtu
passe aléatoire
il reste qui y vivent est nominé dans la
vase y aller qu'il y allait qu'elles ne
sont pas je vous dis un truc mais
surtout je viens de trouver une règle
alors voilà je vous dis non mais oui
mais c'est perdu
vous êtes éliminés merci je te rends
vient de tomber greg celui qui arrive à
mettre son portable
ici ou ici la fin le but il est gagnant
directement à ne pas mentionner qu'elle
passe des inactifs
non sa mort serait due to qui vivait
alors les deux quelle iv novelli et
christine éliminé joji les camps
continuent l'aventuré
[Applaudissements]
alors alors alors on gagne ou on gagne à
faire une vers de dire quelque chose
géraldine maillet me dit cyril vous
n'avez pas tirer pourquoi je n'ai pas
tiré a mais a déjà deux éliminés donc je
vais pas je vais tirer
ben voilà peut choisir et peut-être que
vous allez dans la maison voilà voilà
ah oui et ben voila merci oui eh ben
merci comme le règlement comme d'hab
s'il vous plaît qui dirait pas si vous
n'aimez pas signer ou est pas le boss
n'en dégoûtez pas les autres eu d'accord
s'il vous plaît est ce que quelqu'un qui
peut remettre le truc sur le portable je
ne peux pas tout fait mais je ne peux
pas juger
j'ai des dossiers à traiter toute la
journée j'ai des chiffres qui tombent
tous les quarts d'heure ce qu'est ce que
tu veux tu veux que je meure à l'ex
guérilla alex des richesses
lyon va lancer deux lacs
c'est pourquoi je connais que les blast
des mecs souvent parce que je vois quand
je mets les juifs je paye guerrier allez
vas-y mosseri 1er ahmed pas la coupe à
la maison un peu d'humour ne fait pas de
mal de vols merci je vous demander de
vous m 2 par là bas d'accord à côté un
séminaire s'il est le laisse éliminé
vous allez avoir non non non les élèves
de leur art d éliminer a dit non mais
t'es là bas on y reconnaît nous d'ali
baba à côté de david et si et vous
pouvez participer aux platines et vous
allez vous casser le moule à mouscron là
je m'étais vous la loge même bien des
attentions premier match jean michel mr
contrebasse et batterie
moi ce que j'aime ce que j'aime c'est la
tête de shine et devait gérer sur la
tête de ma mère et regarde le coucou on
dirait qu'ils regardent la finale dames
ils sont comme à son frère vorace trad
ouf
banal ou alors attention tella tella
voilà c'est chaud c'est durant l'homme
tensions latentes ont mis à sac isabelle
alors là je vous demander s'il vous
plaît de baisser un peu le sont car
c'est lé plus de 70 en bresse apple sont
d'accord on y va c'est lé plus qu'à
faire alors on y va les préfère se dire
ça il ya des gens qui pensent réellement
que j'ai cet âge a été stoppée net
ouais mais c'est son truc qu'il la
retire même allez vas-y tu veux pas
lancer que zain dont plutôt verts ale
qui nous fait gagner et je voulais
c'était en demi finale merci si vous
venez vous assure vous aimez en loge
vous a mis en loterie la dq moi je vous
le dit que vous êtes un des pions quarts
de finale c'est déduites cdc des dieux
du l1 mais naim contre eux c'est la
jurade in my hélas alors là je vous
plais cela serait juste dire c'est le
monde de la littérature mais deux
auteurs en deux auteurs se rencontrent
et ce qui va se passer avec 1,7 alors
mais c'est l'alcool nom alors je vais
vous dire la franche mandat des
championnats benhaim beinheim
sacrificielle
enfin dernier derniers matchs alors je
jean est contre moi vas-y mon chien
appelé mes toiles a pour l'instant c'est
à voir mais s'était passé j'ai failli
perdre première demi-finale gilbert
baisse contre boujean respectivement
[Applaudissements]
téléphoné je suis là allez on est bas
c'est castaldi qui a été qualifié au
comice mme abbas attention
[Musique]
sa guitare la fa qui savent quand je
gagne vas-y vas-y vas-y force bravo cher
[Applaudissements]
sur la terre rien ne va changer les
règles et je vais à valérie bénaïm oui
et si je bats valérie belin selah c'est
c'est pratiquement un musée c'est
pratiquement impossible
je vous le dis je désignerai d'ailleurs
benhaim annonça la coupe de cheveux je
vous fais avec ce que vous avez fait là
vous êtes attaqué ce que je fais tes
infos condamnant médaille écoutez moi
bien là il a une allure assez moche mois
il fait moche et je trouve ça très bien
que je vais battre ben haim oui non si
vous nous rejoignez on doit ramener ce
qu'on appelle la coupe à la maison la
coupe est ici et il y à un grand
concours il faut être le plus près de la
maison le plus près de la maison je le
rappelle je rappelle que celui qui est
dans la maison a gagné 1,5
le gagnant désignera celui qui se fera
faire une coupe de footballeurs par
notre ami david qui est ici qu est le
spécialiste
il a coiffé les plus grands dont paul
pogba il n'a pas encore fait mais paul
futur qu'il aime rétrocession comprenait
un petit peu je le connais un peu le
football léché mais on est en
demi-finale pour l'instant castaldi est
en finale c'est sûr ça m'en fiche
j'étais face à des toiles marocaine
qu'une étoile montante marocaine du
lancer de téléphone à la fin car tôt à
ouarzazate l'année dernière
et une fois de plus elle a mérité son
appellation de petit génie né l'abordage
alors il faut l intention cyril s'il
vous plaît on va pas reprendre ce que
vous donnez des tricheries ou le gagner
en trichant donc alors que dans notre
cas l'avis de friggit aux
téléspectateurs c'est chaud les gens
sont là oui on en a l'habitude et
pendant la publicité
christine kelly la sorte non mais non
[Rires]
c'est moi qu'on a loupé ont voulu
soulever pour une raison qui m'échappe
d'ailleurs ce que je voulais regarder ce
qu'ils avaient sur les téléphones
regarder les messages en fait chez
blizzard et j'avais oublié qu'il était
papa voilà vous avez vu qu'elle avait
oui oui trio la main oui normalement
c'est donc vous souhaitez invalidé hors
jeu n'était arrêté de remède ne tenais
pas à briser si l'animateur qui joue
aussi au jeu avait lancé je vais lancer
à l'été s'il vous plaît
voilà georges frêche à lui voilà on
verra tzigane segan on pourra dire que
nous rentrions défricher mais bon ça me
fait peur cyril allez vous avez à son
syrie n'est jamais meilleur que sous la
pression mais oui
[Applaudissements]
c
m
sega ce qu'il est dans la maison
[Applaudissements]